luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys anna welcome back to my
show this is um powered by icon plus a quick news
announcement for you so icon is joining the
pokestop ecosystem so polka dot power chains
um carla moonbeam edgware plasm will be
the first being integrated into icons btp
interoperability solutions so always a lot
of dpi news coming out icon at the moment
now this is um sponsored by blockfy so quick shout
out to them you can get up to i think it's 8.6
interest on your usdc so i use them give them a
go they're pretty cool now joining me today is
a pretty interesting guest i've been very
excited to speak to him um it is the head
of the bitcoin family dd the family that invested
absolutely everything and bitcoin was just at
uh nine i think it was 900 so let's bring him
in didi welcome to the show how are you doing
hi leah thank you for having me on your show
man it's amazing i'm doing amazing i'm in mexico
playing the comment i have the view of an amazing
beach and i'm an amazing woman in crypto so my
name is already perfect good i love it your energy
is always so upbeat and it's so brilliant and
i just want to learn more about your story because
you put was it absolutely everything the house the
cars just everything into bitcoin yeah everything
you know i started mining bitcoin in 2013
and then in 2013 14 it was this huge treasure i
started not to believe anymore in bitcoin i lost
my trust and then in 2016 i picked up again and
then and that was the moment and after i lost my
father of cancer and i needed to change life and
i started to pick up everything again and i saw
the community growing and that was the moment for
me to go all in and then yeah we sold our house
i sold two companies i sold two cars my motorbike
the kids clothes the kids toys the kids crossed
my wife's 70 pairs of shoes i took pension funds i
took the kids savings i cooked our savings we went
all in we just went living on a campsite we went
all bitcoin and then we had the bull run of 2017
and then life changed into a life let's say
a roller coaster ride as a bitcoin family
i'm just so blown away i just think that's
insane so just i want to go back a little bit
before i before i ask you about you know the
stress of doing all of that but before i get
into that how did you first hear about bitcoin
because you said you were mining in 2013 right
yeah you know i grew up just like a
normal year i was very mutualistic
i was very egoistic i had this mosque you know
work walking around the world the end of the
globe and showing who you are but you not are but
at that time i built up some companies and one of
those companies there was an internship and
this guy comes into the company and he's like
did you ever hear about bitcoin i didn't
know what your internship can be about it
what what do you suggest we do uh yeah you can
mine bitcoins maybe i can build a mining rig
and then we start to mine bitcoins that will
be my project okay that's perfect let's do it
so um instead of just y miner i bought for thirty
thousand use the dollar and miners and we started
to empty one office and that empty became a mining
office so we started buying all the mining rigs
and that was in 2013 and that was my first
connection to bitcoin it was like you know
i got fascinated by the story you know that it
was disrupting the monetary system but i got also
fascinated because i want to become a millionaire
at that time in my life i was a young guy wanting
to become a millionaire and you know it was
a revolution that could make me a millionaire
and that was for me the trigger and then i said
to the guy okay let's do it and we tried and we
involved some more friends that had more knowledge
about technical stuff and all that stuff and we
had a lot of heat in the office we didn't know
how to handle that so we called the wheat yeah
we call the weed growers from the netherlands and
we told them how do you handle the heat while you
grow your wheat plant uh yeah we do it like this
so we cop a death system into the minor office
and that is how we started to play around with
mining bitcoins and at the crash and we changed
from bitcoins to dogecoin so we met millions of
bitcoins and then in 2014 we had this huge crash
in december my father called me and he said diddy
i diagnosed cancer we have one more year to live
and that is when i stopped everything you know i
hired managers to run the companies i didn't pay
attention to bitcoin anymore i just invested
all my time in the last year with my father
and when he died in 2016 then again it all started
then it started again i saw the forbes growing
so more and more people talking about bitcoin i
saw the price increasing and then again was the
step for me to talk to my wife and tell her maybe
we should just travel the world and go all in
so okay so everyone wants to be a millionaire and
when you know bitcoin i mean i first heard about
bitcoin i think it was also 2013. but i didn't
have the same mentality as you i wasn't like
oh yeah that sounds like something that which
could get me to becoming a millionaire so what
convinced you what was it was it the technology
or would you say it's a little bit of luck tell
me no no at that moment we were already because i
had a huge burnout after the funeral of all that
stuff in 2016. so i decided to start to travel
with my world with my family across the world we
went to thailand and to to get a mental physical
mindset reset you know i needed a break with the
b of bitcoin but then during that break um i found
out i was so happy i was more happy than i had all
the employees and the companies i was just on
the beach building the sand castle with my kids
and that made me happy so we we kind of roll into
the system where we were traveling through asia
vietnam the philippines indonesia and we saw
so many poor people that didn't have an address
that couldn't fulfill the kyc requirement
to get a bank account and at the same time
i saw the beautiful asset bitcoin group that was
giving them exactly that is so for me that trip
of the first three months was perfectly timed i
saw that more than eighty percent of the world
was dissonant of the monetary system i saw the
solution i saw a revolution i saw happiness on
myself and my family so for me it was all puzzles
were falling into a place and that was the perfect
time that was bad just go all in i started to
believe in bitcoin and uh you know so sorry
there is really something to be said about
minimalism and just getting rid of everything so
given you guys you know you found so much peace on
this journey was it hard to convince your wife and
you know just to give up everything go well then
you said you even even your children their savings
you put into bitcoin was that hard to convince
her i uh of course that took a few my times and
put on the beach and a few bacardi cokes but my
wife was not that was not the maturistic part of
the family it was more me that always was in the
home for uh for money and my wife was also already
doing yoga meditation she was more the factor that
kept the normal standard in the family you know
and so for her it was i think for her the biggest
part was the the leading by example you know as a
family if you have children you can continue the
life of your head and your kids will copy your
behavior will copy that lifestyle and i wanted to
break that lifestyle my wife wanted to show the
kids as well we need to break this circle so that
our kids get a better future we need to prepare
them for the different future decentralized future
a future where you don't need ownership of a house
or a car or a bike or a bank account that is what
we need to prepare the kids for so the passion for
my wife is always about the children and so
for her for her it was also easy to take the
step because it was about leading by example
for the kids don't go and run and accumulate
don't go and run an acute wealth but start to
accumulate happiness day by day you can force
your kids to run the hamster wheel and to make
money money money or you can have them run the
hamstring and making happiness every day and
there was a switch that was for her the main
reason to accept the crazy idea of selling the
house and everything from bitcoin but you know
it but you're you're moving right so when we first
were chatting you were in portugal now you're in
mexico it's the goal to just keep traveling and
keep going or is it to find a base no it's um
it's it's both it's been day by day we don't have
a plan we are the most unstructurized company you
will ever meet we don't even know where we will
end up tomorrow or the day after we we we just go
with the flow but we have the opinion and the
vision that ownership of real estate a house
is not needed to live life you know the future
of technology is evolving so fast that a house
will become an own entity on the blockchain a
car will be a self-driven car on the blocking
i will be stepping in the car driving from a to
b and paying the kilometers i driven and this car
will be driving to the garage to rip yourself and
pay that guy again with the wallet and this is the
same with houses this is the vision we have about
the future and we why would i now tie myself to
a house to real estate it has like a return of
a business that is really [ __ ] in my opinion
well i could be invested full of bitcoin that
has the biggest return investment and that
is how i show my kids you know you don't need
that house you don't need a house to feel safe
i know we were we we grew up in the 90s and you
were taught in the schools you need to have a big
house and then you need to provide for your family
and then you get the safety network and you feel
relaxed no i feel relaxed when i'm free
to go wherever i want whenever i want if
they close the stores and the restaurants and
the lock down in portable i want to be going
and that's what we have i'm going to mexico
everything is open life is normal that is
the freedom bitcoin and blockchain for me is more
about freedom than it is about accumulating wealth
and i think that is what we want to show our kids
the community and everybody else in the world i
totally agree with you and and i absolutely admire
it so much and when i when i you know learned
about you guys and figured figured out you know
you you are moving from place to place the first
thing which came to mind which i've been dying to
ask you is how does it work then with like your
kids education now before you answer i totally
i think i know you're gonna say anyway but like
i totally think that the education system is trash
anyway i think that it teaches you um the absolute
opposite of freedom so i can totally understand
if you know you wanted them to opt out of that but
talk to me how does that work because they're not
going to school do they have friends how can they
have friends if they're moving from country to
country so that's uh you know in the beginning
we traveled really fast and and yeah and we we
are now adjusting to slow travel so we stayed
for five months on politico before that five
months island now two three months in mexico
so so we are slowing down the pace because
of the social context and everything um the
kids the first two years we unschooled them
uh because if you want to respect your kids
uh you can't just stop the normal thing and go
into online schooling you just unschool them
you just stop you just let them be kids for some
time so that they get in this new rhythm of life
and then from that moment on uh when the reset
was done let's say that they were getting used
and to be not going to school and then we started
to homeschool and online school then there are
beautiful projects like galileo which is an online
school for digital nomad families where all kids
yeah they gather every morning for 30 minutes in
a zoom call with more than 12 kids talking about
the things that kids will want to learn and and
they guide the kids in their um they're tragic my
daughter wants to learn about the stars and about
the sea and about elephants so that month she will
spend that and their coaches will help her to find
subjects to read write and investigate that event
or the stars so it's a different style of um of
educating but they still learn my youngest kid
i've never gone to school her name is jessa
she's not 10 years old she's never gone to
school she writes she reads she speaks english
she speaks dutch she understands german tries to
speak german and she knows a lot about animals she
knows a lot about human mindset connecting people
so they learn different things in different ways
and it also has disadvantages this lifestyle has
disadvantages it big disadvantage should be
social context of course there is a lot of
digital moment families we we have a huge group
of more than 50 families that we meet all over the
world and we live in a few months in portugal and
then in thailand so the kids can connect but it's
different than they go to school in a daily days
but nowadays the difference isn't that big anymore
all the world is homeschooling you know
and even when we visit the netherlands
most children are not playing football on
the streets anymore they are at home playing
fortnite or any other computer game the world is
changing and we can fight against it and we try
and we try to minimize the use of telephones
and laptops for a kiss but when we try it as a
family and we send them out to play with other
kids but there are no other kids on the street
it's it becomes more normal so they have snapchat
they have facebook they have all that stuff they
have digital friends they have friends all over
the world where they have you know chat with
every day in different languages and sometimes
we go back to the netherlands to pick up the
friendships that they had in the schools when you
still went to school you know but it's you become
part of a huge family which calls itself the
digital moment family and we are not the only
family we are the only family that went all into
bitcoin probably but all the other families they
do other digital normal work they do podcast they
do coaching and they develop websites but there
are so many people traveling you know i think it's
natural i think if you go back 50 years or 100
years we all were nomads we were um we were people
that were traveling we started to go and live in
villages and cities because of the jobs jobs were
created the industrial revolution made us go there
and live there and get that same education and
same job but now now we are going into the new age
where jobs are being disconnected from a location
i can work from home i can work online i can even
work for a company on different locations in the
world so i see us as humanity shifting them back
to nomadic lifestyles where we make the
use of the tools of blockchain and bitcoin
that make it able to have this decentralized
lifestyle that you make use of houses all over
the world cars whatever you need we already
see the preface airbnb and all that stuff
you know that's the pre-phase this is going to be
houses only on the blockchain in the future that
you and me will be paying the time that we spend
that's a new nomadic way of living and that's
because we get a universal currency cryptocurrency
maybe bitcoin another one maybe a central bank's
digital currency whatever you believe but
it is going that way in my opinion i'm sorry
no no no no i i do agree with you i'm just
fascinated um by the homeschooling and the digital
nomad syllabus for the kids i'm really fascinated
by that and i'm also fascinated by how they'll
turn out you know in comparison to how the the
let's just say the average child going to school
turns out these days i sort of i sort of feel like
we're um schooling is very much to prepare us to
work in the factories and to work for the man
and so on and so on so i'm just i'm so interested
to see how the digital nomad child grows up you
know what it is like if these schools are still
preparing those kids for those jobs in 10 years
times there is no job in the factory anymore
it's robots being building cars it's robots doing
everything how can you prepare kids for that you
know i will give you an example i would thought my
oldest daughter now to become an entrepreneur like
i was walking on the beach i was doing a video and
she was like dad i want to make my own bitcoins
i'm 15. you know i need to be independent okay
um let's let's think about how you can become
bitcoins because there's no employee
that's going to pay you bitcoins yet
and then she's like yeah i don't know how so maybe
you'd like to design a beautiful t-shirt and then
she said no no i want to i want to design a hoodie
so i taught her the whole process so on the beach
we were thinking about what kind of food he needed
to be yeah it needs to be a pink hoodie and it
needs to be something with bitcoin on it so i went
home with her to the apartment i thought okay so
now we are going to do it let's see how difficult
or how easy it is we went on to fiverr i told her
look we are going to ask people to design a cool
original bitcoin logo from that hoodie and she's
like what are they how much are they going to ask
let's see what they offer so we put the you know
we put the project online at fiverr they gave
us an offer i told her did not negotiate the guy
asked ten dollar i told her to offer two
dollars at the end she paid four dollars for the
for the logo then we went to her online shop you
know that's just drop shipping uh i told her this
this is the pink hoodie we pasted the logo on it
and then she was like wow ready who's going to buy
it that is now the next step that is marketing so
we called it um we texted uh the bitcoin team you
know for twitter as well and ask her hey if i send
you this hoodie pink one bitcoin would you please
wear it in one of your twitters or your videos
or whatever and she said yes so my daughter was
like oh she's connecting to another team she's
selling her the hoodie for free she was wearing
it and we sold 40 of those hoodies that month so
in one month i had educated her completely in the
concept of just being creative in your mind using
all the stuff that is already there designers
online shipment marketing and putting that
into a concept which makes you bitcoin
and that lesson told my kids way more than any
autonomy that i have read on the higher economics
but that's how i totally i totally agree with
you by the way just want to let you know that
your camera's frozen oh you've actually started
moving again you're okay so your camera's frozen
but i can hear you perfectly um i can't see you
now it's okay it's okay it's kind of the issue
that we had before we went live but oh no i
think i think we're okay i think we're okay
um yeah no you're fine you're moving and your
voice is fully clear so it's fine to be honest
um but that that's unbelievable and that is the
best education that is the ultimate education that
um people or kids of the future need not this bs
in school about i'm sorry i'm going to say like
algebra and the cell of a plan and and all
this stuff you know it's just insane but in
terms of living off bitcoin so you've never
sold it is that right you've never sold it
no i exchanged bitcoins to stable currencies
to buy back more bitcoins but we never went
back to bank accounts because we don't own a
bank account anymore already for four years so
how do you how do you buy things and you know
some places obviously aren't always going to be
crypto friendly so how do you purchase stuff
especially airbnb is that how you get your your um
your homes so it becomes more easy and more easy
in the beginning it was difficult but nowadays
it's not difficult anymore you know you have all
online booking sites that accept bitcoin already
i don't know if you can name them we get travala
excel trip these are all like bit by flight flight
by bit you can buy your flights your bouquet all
the hotels i can book on booking.com or apartments
i can book with bitcoin directly so the house is
not that difficult anymore um all the other stuff
i just need to convince people you know when i
arrived at portable i found a beautiful house
in airbnb that i want to run for a few months
and i text private and you need all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] to reach them with the number because
airbnb blocks this of course and then i got income
i got into contact i went there and i said can
we have a barbecue i want to rent your house for
six months we had a bbq at dinner i told them we
are the bitcoin family i showed him an article in
french because it was a french owner and i told
him i want to pay him bitcoin and that is how
you can get the double for your house in the next
couple of months and he's left but he agreed so
the house was covered i walked to the beach to
the beach bar and then the beach brothers guys
go polo and paulo was there asking me for the
bitcoin t-shirt i told them yeah we travel the
world can i spend bitcoins at your bar please can
i spend them at the end of the week and we uh you
know make a bill because the fees are a little bit
too high in bitcoin i educate them about the fees
then i start a wallet on their telephone and that
whole week i drink my buckeye cokes my lunches on
the beach and at the end i paid in bitcoin this
guy is now calling me and he's like wow did he
in two weeks time i made double just because
the increase in the privacy that's also bitcoin
and that's how it with the sailing knockoff
and portugal that's how i did it with the hotel
here in mexico that's how i do it with
the restaurants for all the other cases
we use all those online platforms like bit refill
where we buy coupons to spend at the meccans or
where we buy a coupon to spend it alibaba or at
whatever online shopping and then we still of
course at the end we have a bitcoin debit card and
with the debit card of course i can pay all over
the world as well these are supported non-kyc
debit cards kyc debit cards you became very
creative in the last couple of years and we are
using any possible tool to just live on bitcoin
for us it's surpassing the banking system and we
are succeeding in this already for four years now
which is the non-kyc debit card you're using if
you don't mind me asking i will i will send you
that in the private chat okay thank you i'm just
curious about that one that one's interesting um
that's so cool i bet the the guy in portugal must
have been absolutely over the moon because when
you arrived it was what at the end of 2020 so
bitcoin was just about to hit new all-time highs
so he would have doubled his money uh i thought
to pay all the bills when bitcoin was around 20k
20k and it's now 60k so yeah the guy he doubled
not only but he started to call me during that
time and he's like are we going higher 30 cases
yes so he started to buy bitcoins more and more
and he started to tell his friends in portugal
again you should be buying bitcoins so this is
a small thing you can do as a bitcoiner because
you believe you go to a bar you have a chat so you
have fun you have a drink you have a chat and you
have the chance to convince somebody to understand
and believe the whole bitcoin concept and and
maybe you use it avoid paying taxes maybe he will
use it um you know for for any other reason that
doesn't matter bitcoin is for everybody but we as
a community should start to educate everybody i
made a video today about i could upload it in an
hour or something it's about you know that i can
see that people are seeing bitcoin more than a
financial tool to accumulate wealth or to protect
wealth and the video today i will post on youtube
i imagine people on it's not only that it's also
a disruptive immutable 24 7 usable borderless
peer-to-peer cash that is going to involve
everybody into the humanitarian system
it's more than just accumulating wealth
it's changing the world we you me all the
influencers we are changing the world maybe we
don't realize it yet i do but in 10 years time
we will look into these videos and we will like
we were at the forefront of changing this whole
monetary system into a harness one that is now
accessible for everybody and everybody still has
full control on their money that's a change
that we need to make though we are making it
i love that you're converting people on the
way i think that's my favorite part of this
you're just like kind of hustling your way through
this and you're just like guys trust me you're
gonna double your money let me pay you in bitcoin
but i have a question for you so what happened
back in 2017 um during the bear market you know
went from 20k down to 3k i know you are obviously
still in profit because you bought in at 900
but were you concerned that you'd made a mistake
no we were not completing profits we started
to buy 900. my pension fund went in at 6 000
us all up at bitcoin um but of course we changed
a little bit on the top like 20 30 we changed it
to the stable bond and you know um for us we had
this new mindset of living minimalism it was not
about the money anymore we were prepared to lose
everything if only we could change life the money
that we didn't care it was you know and we came
into this rollercoaster ride because of the move
uh documentaries were being made interviews they
they were invasive invading our life completely
we didn't even have time to think about selling
bitcoins and trading it was our life was disrupted
in a way that you can't imagine we would live
in a campsite they were flying from wall street
was flying was um australia ukraine our life was
like we couldn't even see what we were doing at
that point and you know and in 2018 and 19 yeah
life costed us about one to two bitcoins a month
but now lighthouse is lost one bitcoin a year you
average out you know it's that's the strange thing
you drive this scholar roller coaster ride but
you know in the beginning when we made the huge
kind of profits we took almost 36 percent i think
i i still have the calculation summary man and we
gave that to children and and then we had these
dip from 12k to 6k which i didn't expect and then
6k to 3k which i didn't expect but we just needed
3k a month to live life so for us there was
not an issue we were just looking a simple
line in thailand and now yeah now now we have a
little bit more luxuries now you know this year
my kids asked me the first time in portugal can
we now for once spent christmas in a house so
portugal you i rented a beautiful villa you
know which rule everything now mexico we have
a penthouse with a private pool because now i
show the kids if you'd just take two steps back
for two years and don't spend too
much and try to save your bitcoins
you can live life to the fullest now here
in mexico you know and we are building
a school in mexico for poor kids still all the
profit i make youtube books t-shirts trading
everything goes into a fund and i use this fund
to help poor people all over the world we are
building a school in tulum here for very poor kids
and we are buying a house in venezuela 20 home
kids without parents we are doing i'm just giving
it away because i discovered the secret of life
is not about greed and accumulating it's about
giving the more you give the more you receive
the more you give happiness the more you receive
happiness the more you give money away the more
it comes back from other ways in life it's a
it's a completely different lifestyle maybe
some people think it's floaty or flowy whatever
you call it hippie i i i don't know you know we we
do it that way and it's our way we try to lead by
example some people will like it some people won't
i respect everybody if you want to buy
a lamborghini from your profits happy
i'm very respected to you you do it if you want
to build a school i also respect you know it's
we are all different people and we need to start
to learn to respect each other for our opinions
whatever opinion it is yeah i think you know you
definitely attract what you put out there i say
you know the happier you the happier you are
for other people the more happiness will find
you it's all about having that abundance
mindset and i think you were rewarded
for your minimalism because imagine if you had
actually splashed out during that bear market
you know and you were living in all these luxury
places then you wouldn't be able to have what
you have now um so you were totally rewarded for
your minimalism exactly and i think everybody will
be rewarded for their minimalism not only in
money but also in happiness if people learn
to understand that not having their back on your
luggage or your bag of a house and all that stuff
you you can't i can't explain how much freedom
this will give you you know as a man i always
had this pressure on my shoulders you know
you need to provide you need to have security
you need to have a house you need to have cars
when i couldn't let go of that thought and just
be there for the family and have happiness the
life changed completely it's it's strange it's
i don't know how it works i just agree uh on
that award and i just go yeah there absolutely
do you do you have any belongings then like
how light do you travel like how light are
we talking you've obviously got some laptops
and some phones but what else have you got so
we travel always with four backpacks so all we
belong is in those four backpacks and we have
of course four backpacks but we also have um
how do you call it uh that laptop back once
so we have uh yeah a trolley let's say trolley
with the laptops and the cameras and everything
but the clothes and all the other belongings
are for backpacks we don't own anything
we don't own anything we have a car in madrid in
spain now park the bitcoin car the one that you
saw driving but um that was kind of sponsored
and it's not even registered on our name but we
are driving it um but um no we there's no
ownership of anything we have a few boxes
stored in spain and my parents-in-law that
contain my pictures for my father and mother
um that contain the kids um how do you say this
the the things that kids care about from the past
yeah their pictures are there but that's like five
boxes or something in spain and the rest is just
yeah what we travel with [ __ ] backpacks i'm i
really i'm honestly envious i love it so much my
heart just like is just filled with warmth
i really love it honestly i'm wondering we
have quite a few people watching right now we have
quite a few questions i'm wondering whether you'd
fancy doing an ama um if people want to write
in some questions would that be okay with you
um it's 10 to 10 yeah we can i still have yeah
we still have done that let's do it yeah how long
do you have about like 10 minutes or something
like that no we have more than like 25 minutes
okay cool all right so guys if you're interested
we're gonna do an ama so just write your questions
now for the bitcoin family and we'll go through it
so there is one question actually which i'm just
going to scroll up on um somebody asked about
taxes and that's a really interesting one so
which country do you belong to where are you
a citizen of you know who owns you basically
so we have a dutch passport and if you become
creative and as a digital nomad you don't need to
be registered anywhere you can travel and as long
as you don't have bank accounts there is no way
that they can force you or make you or have you
pay taxes because you're living off your capital
in the netherlands you have a capital tax um of
1.3 so if i would be registered in another i would
be paying 1.3 and portugal you pay zero percent
on bitcoin so if you register in portugal you
have zero percent of bitcoin in mexico you also
have zero percent on bitcoin and switzerland you
also still have 0 so in many countries um you
could be registering to uh to just avoid paying
tax on your cryptocurrencies be aware we still
don't have bank accounts we don't have any assets
so it becomes more easy you don't have that and
only have cryptocurrency you just choose that
country it doesn't tax cryptocurrency and you
need to just let go of that other country so
i know it's different for people living in the
us uh they still protect us even if they register
in other countries but i was lucky to be a dutch
citizen and then there is more opportunities yeah
so yeah i actually no go for it sorry what are
you going to say so i'm not against uh paying
taxes i'm against how the systems build up i think
it's [ __ ] i think it's stupid i think they still
don't understand that they can just turn around
the tax system in a in like in a minute and
have everybody pay taxes uh but that's that's
attempt to um you do find out how that works
but you know as long as i need to pay taxes i
will pay my taxes but you know percent political
zero percent so i'm pretty happy you're doing
good somebody asked um but what about access to
exchanges you need to show utility bills but you
don't need an exchange do you you don't exchange
so we we used that at the beginning like kraken
and all this stuff in 2016 so that one is the
only one when i was still educating myself in
this industry but nowadays we use the non-kyc
exchanges to trade you know i'm not using which
okay we'll see a change anymore you know it's uh
i i don't have the need to buy altcoins anymore
on those kyc regulated exchanges and i will trade
bitcoin i will trade all the coins that it's
possible to trade on those non-kyc exchanges
and i will buy my bitcoin peer to peer otc deals
along the beach while i'm drinking my bugatti gold
with that otc dealer i i have a journey i
learned a lot about it but i also learned that
the community is that big now but everybody
now and then is in the need to sell or buy
bitcoins and you as a community can solve this it
worked the same time and the same way in history
you were actually your ex for milk we didn't need
any government or governance or government or bank
to make us a camille correct you don't need those
people anymore to live and to eat bitcoins for
money or whatever it's all possible it's not that
difficult anymore sorry how long no no oh my god
don't apologize i'm honestly absolutely fascinated
i love it this is this is my dream so i'm living
vicariously through you right now um while we're
in lockdown here in the uk so there you go um but
when do you see bitcoin being um widely adopted so
i know we're seeing loads of institutions jumping
in right now and it's obviously helping with the
price action but how do you see bitcoin playing
out do you see it you know people doing what
you're doing and living off it and it being that
global currency or do you think things will sort
of continue as they are they'll evolve but it'll
be more of a store of value like gold is yeah so
yeah i i have my opinion on this but um you know
i also need to say up front i'm not a financial
advisor or anything else and i also think we
live day by day so it can go in any direction
bitcoin will stand to be a peer-to-peer cash
and at the moment the fees are too high to be
a peer-to-peer cash and if the second layer
applications will evolve like liquid or lightning
network maybe it will be converted to your cache
if not it was baked into a hot uh way that
into the software that we can hard fork it
which makes it possible to be at all the other
currencies developed that maybe will evolve to
peer-to-peer cash um i i'm not a member
of this maximum as maximus in the way of
i only love bitcoin i love the community i
think we as a community need to work together
all currencies to disrupt the monetary system so
not fight each other i'm better you better no we
fight the monetary system whatever cryptocurrency
succeeds in becoming p2p cash in my opinion at the
moment i see the bitcoin movement going more into
the store value and i can see it becoming the new
uh 21st century gold i can see it becoming the
most important tool in the world not for us
anymore but for governments bought for countries
and and you see this already if you read through
the news you can exactly see what is happening
i'm going to try to explain it very shortly
so 12 months ago i started to read articles about
iran iraq pakistan venezuela turkey that they were
incentivizing their power plans to mine bitcoins
countries incentivizing their power plans to mine
bitcoins those countries were all the countries
that were under the u.s sanctions they didn't get
dollars anymore to do input and export they
mined bitcoin for 12 months and now the last
couple of months they came out and they said now
we as a country pakistan iran venezuela turkey
we are going to use bitcoin legally for import
and export so they are bypassing the u.s sanctions
china wants to be the biggest bitcoin miner
the united states wants to be the biggest
bitcoin miner all countries want to be the biggest
bitcoin miner why do you think that it's happening
it is not because they think it's a scam of
multi-level marketing it is because they as
governments as central banks are creating a new
monetary system they are crashing this current
monetary system to create a new one which is
called central banks digital currencies and
those central banks digital currencies are going
to be backed up by digital gold and that is why
that is the only reason that all those billion
dollar companies billionaires now got a legal
framework to put bitcoins on their balance sheet
to buy bitcoins because the politicians allowed
it and when politicians start to make a framework
and allow those billion dollar companies to buy
bitcoins you know that there is a bigger game
going on because those donors will be backing up
their politicians during the new run for president
that is how economics work bitcoin is going to
be goal of the 21st century and all the billion
dollar companies and billionaires are now already
exchanging their reserve currencies into that new
store of value goal and the banks are playing the
same game they played with gold we were used
to have our gold in our homes we as a coil boy
or indians we had a house full with gold then we
were getting afraid because there were some people
telling us oh but you can be robbed and then the
banks evolved and then the people were putting
their gold into banks to keep them safe and then
the banks were custodial service for your gold
do you see the dots now the banks are becoming
custodial servers for people's bitcoins they
are playing the game over and over and over again
we need to educate those people yes the bank can
you'll be the custodial service but that is not
your bitcoin not your key not your bitcoin so for
me i think bitcoin is still evolving to be this
digital gold of the 21st century but on the other
hand i still have the hope that the community will
see this in time and will still understand this
revolution of disrupting the monetary system and
taking back the power to the people when it comes
to finance to life to everything else because that
is what bitcoin and blockchain for me is about
i think you make a really interesting point you
know when you talk about the banks and custodial
services because this is such a debate in the
community and it's it's this community is just
full of debates and controversies and there's
this whole idea you know not your keys not your
coins and i'm very much of the mindset you know
not your keys not your coins but i also believe
that eventually not everybody will want to hold
their own um their own keys you know if this thing
really does go mainstream i just i don't think
everybody will want that kind of responsibility
i agree with you and i don't think it's
needed because just just just see it i see
it as a revolution but other people see it just
an evolution it's just minus the r it's the same
word i put the r before in front of it but um for
me you need to understand like the the monetary
system now is built in the same way you have
money and it's digital on bank accounts and you
have cash you're using them both the the thing
is now that if this cash is going to fall away
because there is only seven percent left in
the world that is still physical cash or coins
if that is going to go away we still
need to have an alternative way of
hauling and spending money as cash digital cash
now and that's the only thing people understand if
you would play it safe keep your money on the bank
but be sure to support the revolution that there
is an alternative for that money because that
money can be frozen like we saw in greece like
you saw in cyprus ibc all over the world appear
to peer cash they can't freeze it it's yours
and as long as people understand that there's two
systems and you can use all both systems for me i
don't hate banks no for people love banks let
them know banks i just want to educate people
on this alternative way of keeping track of their
finance or keeping control on their finances and
that's the pure cryptocurrency um so i don't
see a future with only decentralized money i
see a future with centralized parties having
centralized money let them play their game
but i want to be part of that other side of the
world and i don't want to have control i don't
have control of a centralized organization bank
or institution that will call me at the end of the
month and tell me we saw you bought six bottles of
uh bakari this month your alcoholist we're going
to freeze the town because you drink too much i
don't want that control i don't want the social
credit system like it is in china and i don't want
a combination of a financial social credit session
uh credit system combined with digital fiat
hold by the bank that commission is awful
that's awful i can't that's a that's a
horror movie for me no i'm totally with you
yeah yeah no i'm totally with you no don't stop
apologizing honestly i'm really fascinated by this
and i think i think you make such a good point
in that um people now have a choice and that's
what bitcoin gives you know it's not about forcing
people to take personal responsibility it's about
educating them and we now have a choice so i
know that you are um a little bit pushed for
time but one last question um which is really
interesting somebody has said what would you
recommend to someone who who doesn't have any
bitcoin but wants to live just as freely as you
what would your advice be at the moment yeah if
they want to live as free as you but they don't
have any bitcoin what would you advise them
sell everything you have go all into bitcoin
yeah ride the bull run to top a few weeks before
the top exchange your bitcoin into a stable coin
use a huge part of that stable coin to stake
level those high yields while we go into the
bear market in the bear market bottom you buy your
bitcoins and you ride the next four year cycle
and you will be living the same way in beautiful
houses maybe i don't know if i can move
but i can move i will move and i will show you
it's not only me it's also you guys out there
that can live with a view of this here it's
on the beach yeah we can see it's a little
bit frozen but we can see wow i can see it's
beautiful that is possible for everyone and
it's cheaper than paying my mortgage for a house
in the netherlands oh my gosh absolute goals
absolute goals i tell you um dd i want to
thank you so much i've been so excited to
chat to you i'm so pleased that we were able to
do this i know you're moving around a lot but
i think it was really cool that we were able to
schedule schedule this um so thank you so much for
coming on um you're completely welcome i apologize
again that i needed to do it one hour earlier we
are going to go on a boat trip with a guy living
here in mexico and he has built a hotel somewhere
here on a beautiful beach and it will be bitcoin
blockchain hotel so i'm going to have a boat trip
and talk with him and advise him on how we can uh
build this beautiful place here in mexico together
thanks so much i love what you're doing for
the crypto community and i really respect you
i love that there are more and more
women in this community and we need them
because they always keep the community cool fair
and honest and that's what i like about it thank
you so much for having me on your shoulder
yeah thank you so much for coming and enjoy
your boat trip and i think that's so cool that
you're going to teach them all about bitcoin so
thank you so much again thank you everybody for
watching and don't forget to tune in next week
see you soon enjoy your day bye bye keep believing
keep believing there you go see you later